josie is a half cat no she isn't half
cat half something else and she's not a
humanoid with feline features either she
is literally half of a cat actually to
be more precise she is the front half
but an otherwise ordinary black and grey
tabby cat that is ordinary apart from
having no visible back legs or
hindquarters you might think that make
it hard for josie to get around but if
you asked her on how only being a half
cat affects her on a daily basis while
she wouldn't be able to answer you due
to the simple fact that cats generally
can't speak but nevertheless josie will
happily and effortlessly walk around on
her own two legs moving as if she had a
second pair of hind legs in place behind
her her back half isn't invisible it's
as if it's not even there at all not
showing up on x-rays and yet it can give
a slight yield when touched being almost
tangible but not fully despite this
josie suffers no adverse health problems
or any other complications despite
lacking one half of her body
occasionally she doesn't mind having her
semi-corporeal hindquarters stroked
although she will usually get a little
bit scratchy if people try that so how
does the scp foundation keep an anomaly
like josie contained well it turns out
that they don't really need to she's
perfectly harmless and is actually
allowed to roam freely around the lower
levels of the facility she's kept at
casually as you like she slinks around
the corridors passing from one room to
the next of course if cats could talk
then josie would probably tell you that
she has the run of the whole facility
the only real question left is what does
a half cat do when she's left to wander
around a foundation facility completely
unsupervised easy she starts looking for
a ball of yarn josie was sure she'd seen
one somewhere around here one of the
researchers had carried it off for
testing not too long ago her small front
paws patted against the ground as josie
navigated her way to where she last
remembered seeing that coveted ball of
yarn being taken she passed a group of
researchers one of them kneeling down to
give her a friendly scratch behind the
ears just as she closed her eyes and
purred at the greeting a sound coming
from down the hall startled her it was a
low distress sobbing having never been
taught that old saying about curiosity
and cats josie slunk past the
researcher's legs towards the source of
the noise the room that the crying was
coming from had no windows no way for
her to get in luckily josie despite only
having half a body had enough
determination and resourcefulness for
two whole cats around the corner she
knew there was an open air vent and sure
enough she leaped gracefully up to it
with ease the cold metal tunnel was just
big enough to accommodate her little
furry self as she crawled through the
echoing sound of sobs guiding her as she
reached the grate looking out into the
windowless room josie spotted a tall
thin creature sitting with its back to
her its arms would have been long enough
to reach the ground if it had stood at
its full height but for now they were
wrapped tightly around its legs as the
creature rocked back and forth its loud
whales showed that it was clearly in a
great deal of distress although josie
wouldn't be able to understand why
having someone look at its face would
make this slender creature so upset
nearby there was a giant metal cube with
a hole ripped in it while the rest of
the room was empty there seemed to be
several large red smears on the ground
how strange she cocked her head to one
side and meowed tapping one paw against
the air vent grate it seemed pretty
loose with a few good pushes the screws
came free and the adorable half cat
hopped down into the room as she got
closer to the creature she noticed it
had a black bag covering its face little
did josie know an hour earlier a junior
researcher had made the terrible mistake
of putting on a pair of x-ray glasses he
ordered from the back of a comic book as
it turns out these were the only ones to
ever actually work he saw right through
096's containment cube and all hell had
broken loose but josie didn't mind she
decided to endear herself to the strange
shy creature by rubbing up against its
long leg returning the same affection
that it had so rarely been given it bent
down and gently scooped josie up in its
spindly arms the pair of them sat in the
corner together josie getting herself
comfortable on the tall creature's lap
purring as long fingers ran over her
tabby fur the creature being so careful
not to harm the half-cat treated her
like she was as delicate as class it had
briefly stopped crying thanks to its
visitor and as much as she noticed the
sounds of sobbing had ceased josie would
never understand the difference she had
made to
scp-096's day unfortunately it wasn't
long before their encounter was cut
short a legion of guards and scramble
goggles burst into the room to retake
control of the situation the last thing
they expected to see was 096 sitting
calmly with josie on its lap and a bag
covering its face but the sudden
entrance of a security team startled the
poor half cat within a second she had
bolted out of the room shooting under
the legs of the guards and back out into
the facility now that she was back
outside josie recalled her earlier hunt
for a ball of yarn to play with she
still wasn't sure where it had gotten to
maybe someone had moved it pacing over
to the elevator she stared up at the
heavy steel doors the numbers above were
gradually ticking down denoting which
floor the elevator had currently stopped
at of course josie couldn't read so
instead she sat and meowed loudly at the
elevator maybe if she made enough noise
the doors would eventually open
eventually after a few short minutes of
waiting and growling the door slid apart
another gaggle of researchers passed her
by and josie plodded into the elevator
spotting a familiar face one of the
researchers a doctor by the name of
sophie cartwright was still inside and
smiled down at the half cat explorer dr
cartwright had come across josie a few
times enough for the intrepid little
tabby to consider them friends where too
josie dr cartwright asked her hand
hovering over the elevator's buttons as
if in reply josie looked up and meowed
humans always seemed to smile if she
meowed after they'd said something to
her sophie chuckled and pushed the door
close button hold the elevator another
much gravelier voice called a hand or
rather a paw reached out and caught the
doors before they could slide closed it
was another of the foundation's doctors
one with both a considerable reputation
and a very
distinguishing look to say the least dr
kane pathos crow stepped inside the
elevator and pushed one of the buttons
sophie had to force herself to keep her
head down but couldn't help herself from
stealing the occasional glance up at dr
crowe she heard the rumors about a
peculiar anomalous event changing his
appearance but had never seen him up
close before
josie on the other hand couldn't take
her eyes off crowe staring up at him
frozen to the spot and letting out a low
cautious whine if her tail was visible
sophie would have seen it swaying from
side to side as the brave little
half-cat kept her defensive ground
standing between her friend dr
cartwright and her mortal enemy you see
dr crow was a dog or at least a man who
had been turned into something very much
like a dog still capable of speech but
with a distinctively canine body crow
kept to himself the entire ride down
although sophie could feel the tension
between the dog body doctor and her
little half-cat friend out of the corner
of his eye dr crow spotted josie trying
his best to ignore her he let out a low
discomforted growl the kind a dog makes
when they're on edge to his credit he
couldn't really help it the man had been
turned into a canine after all but it
took all his stoicism to suppress a bark
and to stop himself from chasing josie
around the cramped elevator arriving at
her floor sophie stepped down followed
by little josie who moved as far away
from crow as quickly as she could the
doors closed once more and sent him
further down into the depths of the
facility as she turned to look sophie
noticed josie had craned her head up to
check on her oh were you protecting me
josie she asked with a smile bending
down to thank the half cat with a
scratch behind the ears before she could
stay for too long josie and her human
companion parted each heading down
separate winding corridors there was a
funny smell hanging in the air like
something gradually melting and bubbling
only to reform and melt again filling
the half cat's pink nose with a strange
burning scent as she passed a holding
cell something broke josie's
concentration yet again the noise of a
hand tapping at glass she turned and
instantly meowed a greeting to the
second familiar face of the day albeit a
more beaked face kneeling down on the
other side of the glass the black robed
plague doctor waved politely at the dual
pod passerby sitting in front of the
glass hoping to be let in josie gave
another meow i'm quite well the doctor
mused and thou are you my dear he asked
politely josie got up on her back legs
or rather that's what it would have
looked like if she had hindquarters
instead it looked like she was almost
floating in place from halfway down
stretching her front paws up reaching
towards the bird-like face as the masked
doctor playfully tapped his fingers
against the glass to amuse his feline
friend no i cannot let you in i'm afraid
he sighed sounding a touch more
melancholic not that a half cat can
understand the difference in someone's
cadence not all of us here are gifted
the freedom you enjoy my furry friend
freedom is not something this
organization would ever understand no
matter how much they claim to know us
the fact of the matter is they never
really listen from the other side of the
glass josie blankton cocked her head to
one side confused she'd barely heard a
word he said oh but listen to me go on
the plague doctor chuckled wrapping his
fingers in front of the half cat again i
suppose you'll be looking for that ball
of yarn they took for testing i saw them
carrying the box it was in that way he
pointed and josie's little green cat
eyes followed the direction of his
finger barely able to comprehend what
had been said to her she simply meowed
up in thanks and plotted the way she'd
been directed
as cp049 said quietly from inside its
cell watching the half-cat until she had
disappeared from view as she continued
through the lower levels of the facility
josie slipped through doors seconds
before they closed left up onto tables
and dashed between legs that strange
smell was back having caught her
attention and distracted her from her
quest again tracking it to its source
josie suddenly felt uneasy she entered a
room with a huge vat of acid the source
of the burning scent she'd picked up on
though it was what was inside the vat
trapped in a loop of regenerating itself
only to be melted over and over again by
the acid that got her feeling defensive
the vast reptilian monstrosity sensed a
small life form outside its tank and
opened one yellow eye squinting through
the searing burning acid at the tiny
little creature staring up at it the
reptile snarled screwing its now healed
eyes shut and swiping what was left of
its limbs at the glass rearing back
josie gave the monster her fiercest hiss
bearing her fangs at it the beast
usually abhorred other beings finding
all other forms of life unnatural
unforgivable and so detestable that it
would normally stop at nothing to
eradicate them but today a tiny tabby
cat with her entire back half missing
was standing up to the crocodilian
nightmare and it barely had enough will
to retaliate maybe it was just too
lethargic too tired to try anything
today perhaps it didn't think she was
worth the effort or figured it would see
to her along with the researchers and
guards next time it broke free from
containment and went on yet another
killing spree but in josie's mind this
facility was her home and the brave
little half-cat had scared scp-682
into staying put as she trotted away
again she knew that the monstrous
reptile would have to think twice before
messing with her back on track at last
josie rounded the corner and arrived in
a familiar looking corridor she was
certain this was where she'd seen a
researcher carrying the box containing
the string that she coveted sure enough
she could see into the room where the
box had been left noticing a group of
researchers and a human in an orange
jumpsuit were gathered around it a few
were making notes on their clipboards at
a safe distance while the one in orange
stepped closer to the box josie watched
as a single bee flew out of the box her
feline eyes followed it ready to pounce
if it came close enough the man wearing
the jumpsuit was waving his arms trying
to swap the insect away a moment later
he grabbed his arm in pain the bee had
gotten agitated stinging him and flying
away somehow surviving as she waited
josie's patience was rewarded the
researchers and the man wearing orange
bustled their way out of the room
offering her the chance she needed to
zip between them and get one step closer
to her prize the room was entirely empty
save for the box in the center sitting
precariously atop a table wiggling
herself as she readied her invisible and
intangible back legs josie shot up just
missing the table's edge she clawed and
scratched at the surface trying to pull
herself up but her lack of hindquarters
made it impossible to climb the rest of
the way dropping back to the floor she
looked up at the table and gave it a
loud indignant meow changing tactics she
started to hop up on one of the table
legs digging her claws into the woodwork
to hoist herself up bit by bit sure
enough her new strategy worked a treat
and josie was presented with what she
had been searching for one final hurdle
was left however the box was closed now
the struggles of only being a half cat
are one thing but not having opposable
thumbs is a difficulty that has plagued
all cats since the dawn of time but not
being able to grab or hold things with
the ease of a human there's one thing
that cats are great at and that's
pushing things over nudging the box to
the table's edge with a gentle boop of
her nose josie eventually tipped the
whole thing off causing it to land on
its side on the floor the lid falling
open triumphantly she jumped back down
to claim her prize expecting to find the
ball of yarn and spend the next few
hours playing with it but something was
wrong the yarn had changed and now it
was
looking at her the ball had started as
yarn and ribbon the perfect play thing
for any half cat or full cat for that
matter but the foundation had been
running their usual invasive tests on it
and since cutting a portion of the
string off it had transformed it was now
a ball of meat functioning blinking eyes
staring out of a mass of overlapping
sinew and blood-red matter the multiple
eyes looked up at the half-cat that had
knocked it to the floor and asked a
single question in a deep voice
emanating from somewhere within its
lipless form
are you
eric
completely unfazed by this josie whacked
the ball with her paw and watched as it
rolled halfway across the room tentacle
segments of its body gradually pulled
the amorphous mass back to where it
started and then asked once again are
you
every
once again josie slapped the ball and
watched it rolled away from her both
completely unaware of who eric was and a
little perturbed that someone had
replaced the ball of yarn with such an
inadequate toy turning her back on
scp-066 josie the half-cat searched for
a way out of the room and went back to
prowling around the facility for
something to entertain herself she
noticed that she was starting to get
hungry maybe if she got lucky one of the
researchers would sneak her a piece of
cheese now go and check out scp-999 the
tickle monster and scp-348 a gift from
dad for more anomalies that are
classified as sweet cute or playful